ce soir et demain je pensais que nous
pourrions nous arrêter sur un texte très
important que celui des séquelles 37 la
vision des ossements desséchés la
résurrection des ossements desséchés qui
est un des textes prophétiques du
prophète ezéchiel parmi les plus connus
et souvent les plus mal compris
d'ailleurs
et en général on allégorie zh
et on spiritualiste texte pour
l'appliquer à l'église
je suis sûr que tout ça on vient entendu
de magnifiques prédication sur ce texte
là où on nous présentait l'église dans
sa misère dans sa pauvreté semblables à
des ossements desséchés
dispersé divisés mais l'esprit du
seigneur allait souffler sur cette
église là est là il allé la réveiller et
les ossements allait se rassembler les
les dénominations divisé allaient s'unir
et ça allait être un magnifique réveil
auquel on allait assister
bon je ne dis pas qu une lecture de ce
type là soit il légitime
dans la mesure en tout cas à une seule
condition c'est que au préalable on est
rendu à césar ce qui revient à césar ça
veut dire que l'on est rendu à israël ce
qui lui revient à savoir que ce texte
comme concernent essentiellement la
résurrection distraire on va le lire
donc ton chapitre 37 d'ezéchiel
la main de l'éternel fut sur moi et
l'éternel me fit sortir un esprit me
déposa mieux de laval et celle c'est
celle ci était rompue d'ossements il me
fit passer auprès d'eux tout autour ils
étaient très nombreux à la surface de
l'aval de l'aval et il était très sec il
me dit fils d'homme c'est hop
pourrait-il revivre je répondis seniors
intérêt c'est toi qui le sait mady
profiter sur ces eaux tu leur diras
ossements desséchés écouter la parole de
l'éternel ainsi par le seigneur
l'éternel assez haut voici je vais faire
venir on vous un esprit et vous vivrez
je passais sur vous des nerfs je ferais
poussée de la chaire sur vous je vous
recouvrirait de pau je m'étais on veut
un esprit vous vivrez vous reconnaîtrez
que je suis l'éternel
jeu prophétisait second ordre qui
m'avait été donné et comme je prophétise
lutins brute voici lui un frémissement
et les eaux se rapprocher les uns des
autres
constaté qu'il y avait des nerfs sur la
chair se mit à pousser et la peau les
recouvrir par dessus je n'avais pas en
ou d'esprit
me dit prophétise par là l'esprit
prophétise fils d'homme tu diras à
l'esprit ainsi parle le seigneur
l'éternel esprit vient des quatre vents
soufflent sur ces morts et qu'ils
revivent je prophétise et selon l'ordre
qui m'avait été donné et puis vint en
eux ils reprirent vie et se taire sur
leurs pieds c'était une très très grande
armée modifie ce dom ces ossements c'est
toute la maison d'israël voilà ça c'est
un mois important
ce n'est pas l'église c'est bel et bien
la maison d'israël est là
l'identification des ossements desséchés
nous est clairement est
expressément donné
voici qu'ils disent nos eaux sont
desséchés notre espérance erevan où il
nous sommes perdus bien prophétise tu le
dire ainsi pas le seigneur l'éternel
voici que j'ouvre vos tombes je vous
fais revenu remonté de vos tombes mon
peuple nous fait revenir sur le
territoire d'israël
vous reconnaîtrez que je suis l'éternel
conjuguer vos tombes mais je vous ferai
remonter de vos tombes mon peuple je
mettrai en vous mon esprit et vous
vivrez je veux rétablir et sur votre
territoire et vous reconnaîtrez que moi
l'éternel j'ai agi et par les oracles de
l'éternel
au début du siècle dernier
pouvait assister à jaffa qui était à
l'époque le plus grand port de ce que
l'on appelait alors la palestine un
spectacle surprenant
des bateaux qui venaient d'europe de
l'est essentiellement du russie
débarquer des jeunes gens avec niveau
d'un got du chapeau haut-de-forme
t canne à pommeau
les jeunes filles avec des ombrelles que
grande crinoline les luttes de du
judaïsme russe polonais
autre lieu
et ces jeunes gens et jeunes filles qui
débarquait à jaffa dès qu'il avait mis
le pied sur la terre d'israël
jetés dans les fossés les canne à
pommeau les ombrelles et crinolines et
chapeau haut de forme et il allait
faire revivre la terre d'israël il aller
cultiver la terre d'israël
c'étaient les pionniers jeunes gens
jeunes filles issues des meilleures
universités de russie de
saint-pétersbourg moscou de varsovie et
autres lieux semblables et qui
avons donné tout un avenir brillant qui
pouvait être brio même si évidemment il
était éminemment compromis par
l'antisémitisme endémique qui sévit
c'est dans ces pays là mais le but
n'était celui justement de faire revivre
la terre ancestrale
et tout autour de cette ville de jaffa
qu'était le point d'atterrissage si
j'ose dire de tous ces jeunes gens et
jeunes filles qui arrivent et d'europe
se créer des villages
les villages qui portaient des noms
bibliques
rishon ici on le premier à sion ness
ziona une bannière à sion migrer israël
l'espérance d'israël
petah tikva la porte de l'espérance et
autres vieux semblables
et parmi ces jeunes gens il y en avait
un qui s'appelait naphtaline berre
l'étang de berre comme beaucoup de ses
camarades
les textes quelqu'un qui avait une
instruction très très poussé qui n'était
pas du tout ils ont un ignorant loin
s'en faut
il était poète et il était musicien
et ils s'étaient établis dans un de ces
villages qui s'appelait ness ziona
laban génération
hélas comme c'était le cas tous les
soirs ces paysans qui
venait d'une journée de travail
harassante
dans ces établissements dans ces
villages qui étaient dix villages
communautaires se rassembler le soir le
travail terminé dans le réfectoire de ce
qui allait devenir plus tard le kibboutz
à cette époque la cen-sad sas ne
s'appelait pas encore le kibboutz et ce
n'était pas encore à proprement parler
un kibboutz tels que cela deviendra par
la suite mais c'était déjà l'embryon de
cette organisation il sera sauvé dans le
réfectoire pour discuter ensemble de la
philosophie de compte pour exécuter une
symphonie de mozart
ou bien pour déclamer des poèmes qui
avait été composée par un des leurs
et à l'occasion d'une de ces rencontres
neftali nerfs s'est levé et a déclamé un
poème chanté qu'il avait composé
lui-même paroles et musique
et ce poème était inspiré directement de
ce texte d'ezéchiel que nous venons de
lire ils disent notre espérance est
morte nous sommes perdus
et le seigneur dizaine ont en quelque
sorte votre espérance n'est pas morte
et naphtaline maire a repris cette idée
et il a écrit ceci non elle n'est pas
morte notre espérance notre espérance
vieille de 2000 ans de vivre comme un
peuple libre sur la terre du sillon et
de jérusalem
est très vite
ce ce champ qui avait été composée par
naphtaline baer a connu un grand succès
dans tous les villages environnants
et on s'est mis à le chanter et non
seulement à le chanter mais en faire le
symbole de cette espérance
qui était celle du peuple d'israël
cette espérance
que le temps était venu de faire revivre
la vieille terre d'israël
et c'est devenu
un hymne qui y était en quelque sorte
que devenu l'hymne aux sionistes
et lorsque l'état d'israël a été créée
quelques dizaines d'années plus tard le
15 mai 1948 il a été décidé que ce poème
qui s'appelait hatikva ce qui signifie
l'espérance allait devenir l'hymne de
l'état d'israël ressuscité
vous avouerez que c'est un peu plus joli
que notre horrible marseillaise
qui elle est loin d'être inspiré par la
bible mais là on est directement sous
l'inspiration du texte biblique lui même
ils disent notre espérance est morte
nous sommes perdus mais voici j'ouvre
votons et je vous fais sortir de vos
tombes je vous ramène dans le pays
d'israël oh mon peuple
est un peu plus tard un autre de ses
pionniers
qu'est ce que c'est il ya un petit
problème
à tigre à
nefta l'iim baer im br
est un peu plus tard un autre pionnier
qui était un grand savant un chimiste
qui avait établi un des premiers
laboratoires
de recherche agronomique ici dans le sud
du pays d'israël
pouvait dire ceci
en israël celui qui ne croit pas au
miracle n'est pas réaliste bon c'est une
parole qui lui sera attribué ce appelé à
une weissmann il devait devenir le
premier président de l'état d'israël
d'autres attribuent cette parole à ben
gourion
bon peu importe
en tout cas quel que soit l'auteur de
cette sentence elle résume bien ce que
ray ce que évoqué ce texte d écrire l 37
ce miracle de la résurrection des
ossements desséchés
et on ne nous n'en finirait pas
d'évoquer tous les miracles qu israël a
connu dans son existence
je voudrais ce soir on évoquait
essentiellement
4,4 miracle qui me semblent être les
plus parlants et les plus spécifiques de
cette résurrection des ossements
desséchés d'israël
le premier miracle c'est la renaissance
de la langue hébraïque
langue qui était morte qui était une
langue morte depuis 2000 ans
et qui n'était plus guère utilisé que
pour le culte la prière et pour les
activités de à caractère spirituel
en quelque sorte cette langue était
réduite à une langue morte
un peu comme le latin qui lui aussi
était une langue qui étaient utilisés
pour la liturgie ou le grec ancien qui
était lui aussi utilisé dans les mêmes
conditions
il était évidemment et il est toujours
tout à fait
hypothétique
utopique d'imaginer que ces langues là
puisse redevenir des langues vivantes
personne d'ailleurs n'a l'intention de
les faire revivre à quelque niveau que
ce soit
et il en était de même en ce qui
concerne l hébreu
et lorsque
le pionner le fondateur du mouvement
sioniste
c'est à dire du mouvement de retour à
sion qui s'appelait tort d'horaires sel
a eu la vision de la résurrection de
l'état d'israël dans une des gens un
acte de foi
totalement insensé
car il avait eu cette folie
de rassembler en
1897 à bâle un premier congrès sioniste
une poignée de jeunes gens comme lui
sans notoriété
sans moyens financiers
sans influence quelle qu'elle soit
pour poser les bases de ce qu'elle est
devenue et l'état d'israël
et à l'issue de ce congrès de bâle où il
avait créé on pourrait dire une sorte de
véritable gouvernement en exil d'israël
n'avait pu écrire dans son journal à
bâle j'ai fondé l'état juif
si je disais cela aujourd'hui tout le
monde me prendrait pour un fou et c'est
vrai il l'était mais dans cinq ans
peut-être les en 50 ans sûrement tout le
monde en conviendra
il fallait être complètement fou pour
s'imaginer que cette poignée de jeunes
gens allaient réussir ce rêve qui était
celui du peuple d'israël vieux de 2000
ans basé sur ces prophéties antique
telle celle que nous venons de lire dans
le chapitre 37 du livre ii du livre d et
qu'elle espérait qu'un jour ces
professionnels et se réaliser que le
peuple d'israël et redevenir une nation
sur la terre ancestrale
or 51 ans plus tard exactement c'était
c'est précisément ce qui s'est passé le
15 mai 1948 israël est redevenu un état
par conséquent théodore hessel était
véritablement un homme de foi
mais
il était comme chacun d'entre nous
la foire est toujours un peu limité
et si l'abus foi dans la résurrection de
l'état de ses infrastructures de
sa terre et cetera
n'imaginais pas du tout que l'hébreu
puisse redevenir une langue vivante
pour lui c'était une langue qui était
définitivement morte et il écrivait dans
son journal qui d'entre nous aujourd'hui
ne serait que seraient capables de nous
demander de demander en hébreu ne
serait-ce qu'un billet de chemin de fer
c'était une langue qui était
complètement dépassé par rapport au
monde moderne dans lequel ces gens là
vivent et est complètement déphasé par
conséquent par rapport à ce monde tel
qu'il était devenu
c'était la vieille langue de la bible il
n'était pas question humainement parlant
de la faire revivre
et cette fois qu'il n'avait pas eu lui
qui s'imaginaient que chanel avait
plusieurs hypothèses
d'abord il avait pensé qu'on parlerait
l'allemand qui était la langue
qui était
celle de la culture européenne la plus
développée à l'époque et puis il s'était
rendu compte que cela risquerait de
provoquer des tensions avec des
communautés qui venaient d'autres
régions et qui avait d'autres langues
et il pensait que finalement le mieux
c'est que chaque communauté continue à
parler sa propre langue
alors vous imaginez la tour de babel
corée était l'état d'israël si l'on
avait été ainsi d'ailleurs on peut se
demander si ce en une langue commune
l'état d'israël aurait véritablement pu
revenir
cette fois qu'il n'avait pas eu 8 et
audresselles un autre pionnier l'a eu il
s'appelait eliezer ben yehuda
et les herbes et neruda était un jeune
étudiant en médecine de saintes puis
saint pétersbourg
il était il avait il faisait partie de
ces mouvements qu'on appelait les amants
de sion
qui à la suite des pogroms qui avaient
ensanglanté la fin du 19e siècle au
début du 20e siècle
avait
pensé qu'il n'y avait plus d avenir pour
eux en europe en europe de l'est en
particulier
beaucoup de ces gens avaient fui aux
états unis créant la plus grande
communauté juive du monde là bas
mais un petit une petite minorité avait
décidé de revenir dans la terre
ancestrale
on les appelait les amants de sion
et les a bénis bouddha avaient été
touchés par ce mouvement là il avait
décidé avec sa jeune femme qui venait
d'épouser de se rendre dans la terre de
ses pères
il avait et c'est arrivé pour cela à
paris où il avait contracté la
tuberculose donc il était resté
plusieurs années à se faire soigner de
sa maladie avant de l'exécuter sans son
projet de se rendre à sion
et sa femme et est allemande
et dès que le jeune couple a posé le
pied sur la terre d'israël et les herbes
et nude à se tourner vers sa femme et
lui a dit ceci à partir de maintenant à
toi et à n'importe qui d'autre je ne
parlerai plus qu'en hébreu
les herbes et nude à était un
spécialiste de l'hébreu il connaissait
cette langue parfaite pas et lui avait
bien compris que il fallait une langue
commune pour la résurrection de l'état
d'israël et que la seule langue commune
qui était possible
qu'ils devaient être adoptés par tous
les juifs qui venait du monde entier
c'était bel et bien la vieille langue
hébraïque
et il a fait ce pari fou insensé de
ressusciter la langue la langue
hébraïque
c'était d'autant plus
insensé que parce que c'était la langue
de l'aqueduc une c'était la langue
liturgique les religieux s'opposait
farouchement à ce qu'elle redevienne une
langue profane et pour eux comme l'avait
dit théodore et c'est l'une était
absolument hors de question que l'on
puisse demander on est branché un billet
de chemin de fer la langue hébraïque
était la langue st ne devait être et
devait être réservée exclusivement à
l'usagé du culte ou de l'étude mais
sûrement pas pour l' usage profane
et les airs bensouda qui a tenu son pari
à partir du moment où il a été dans le
pays d'israël il n'a parlé aucune autre
langue l'hébreu a subi de nombreuses
persécutions
les religieux de jeter des pierres
l'injure est l'insulté
et la situation s'est considérablement
dégradée
lorsque le jeune couple peu de temps
après a eu un enfant
car fidèle à sa ligne de conduite et les
herbes et neruda a interdit que l'on
parle en présence de l'enfant une autre
langue que l'hébreu
lorsque l'enfant a eu six ans et ne
parlait pas encore
ni l'hébreu ni aucune autre langue
et
l'entourage de ben yehuda était indigné
ces actes ont tous une idée folle de
faire ressusciter l'hébreu tu ne te
rends pas compte que tu en train de
faire de ton fils un détraqué
la situation était particulièrement
pénible pour la mère qui voyait
effectivement son enfant devenir un
anormal
et lorsque l'enfant a eu six ans
un jour à l'insu de son mari et l'a pris
à part et là commence à lui parler en
allemand sa langue maternelle
et à ce moment-là
inopinément et geyser est entré dans la
dans la pièce où se trouvait sa femme et
son fils il a entendu sa femme qui
violaient son ordre et qui parlait à
l'enfant allemand et l'isère était un
homme doux pacifique qui se mettaient
rarement en colère mais ce jour-là il
est entré dans une violente colère il
s'est mis à tempêter à se tourner vers
sa fin et il a même levé la main sur
elle et l'enfant a eu peur quand il a vu
son père dans cet état là il s'est
interposé entre le père et la mère et
ils essaient de crier à bas
papa
en hébreu c'était le premier mot qui
n'est jamais prononcé
et ça ça a été un déclic
à partir de ce moment là l'enfant a
commencé à parler l'hébreu
eliezer a gagné son pari il a montré que
l'hébreu et pouvait redevenir une langue
vivante le fils d'eliezer ben-yehuda a
été le premier enfant dont la langue
maternelle est et l'hébreu après 2001
et ça évidemment c'était un véritable
miracle
les airs a créé une école primaire
d'abord où l'on enseigne et on hébreu il
enseigne et s'était lui-même qui
enseignait puis ensuite quand ces
enfants là on grandit une école
secondaire en 1925 on a créé une
université où l'on dansait nuit et en
hébreu est aujourd'hui et bien l'hébreu
est devenu la langue nationale du pays
d'israël
au technion dans les universités
israéliennes on enseigne la physique
nucléaire en hébreu
on chante manon en hébreu
on quand un jeune homme écrit une lettre
d'amour est une jeune fille il le fait
en des termes tirés du livre du cantique
des cantiques
il n'y a pas un seul domaine de
l'existence ou l'hébreu soient
omniprésents et les airs ben-yehuda a
créé l'académie de la langue hébraïque
qui a publié qui enrichit la langue
hébraïque de toutes sortes de vocables
pour exprimer des réalités modernes mais
aujourd'hui le premier des grands
miracles d'israël est véritablement la
résurrection de cette langue
et samedi prochains dieu voulant
nous serons ce qu'on appelle le temple
du livre à jérusalem c'est à dire
l'endroit où sont exposés ce qu'on
appelle les manuscrits de la mer morte
est au centre de cette rotonde
recueil qui expose ses manuscrits il via
le grand rouleau d'isaïe qui fait neuf
mètres de long qui est entièrement
déployée et qui est parfaitement lisible
pour ceux qui connaissent les brevets je
suis toujours profondément remué
profondément ému lorsque je vois des
maîtresses qui sont là avec des enfants
qui sont dans les premières années de
l'école primaire le cp puis les
premières années qui commencent à lire
donc l'hébreu dans leur école et qui
déchiffrent ce texte vieux de 2000 ans
après alors que la langue hébraïque a
connu cette éclipse de 2000 ans et
qu'elle est maintenant ressusciter
ça c'est le premier des grands miracles
d'israël
le deuxième miracle
c'est
l'apparition en israël d'une classe de
paysans
depuis 2000 or depuis
la ruine de jérusalem ou disons un peu
après disons surtout depuis
la conquête tout la conquête musulmane
précisément et l'exil du peuple d'israël
les juifs ont cessé d'être des
agriculteurs d'être des paysans
ils sont devenus des
artisans
des
gens de professions libérales
des gens qui s'occupent de finances
mais il avait complètement perdu tout
contact avec la terre parce que il leur
était interdit de cultiver la terre
parce qu'il leur était interdit de
s'attacher à la terre et par conséquent
il n'avait plus aucune expérience de la
culture de la terre
et
la terre d'israël à cette période là
était devenu aussi un véritable désert
j'évoquerai
deux épisodes même 3 épisode qui
illustre le fait que cette terre était
véritablement redevenu désertique
aujourd'hui une certaine propagande pro
palestinienne voudrait nous faire
accroire que la terre d'israël a
toujours été fertiles qu'elle a toujours
abrité un peuple palestinien pacifique
travailleurs
et que sont venus ces méchants juifs
d'europe qui les ont chassés de leurs
terres qui se sont installés à leur
place
je voudrais évoquer d'abord
un incident qui s'est produit au moyen
âge à la fin de l'époque des croisades
quand un des plus grands rabbins
d'espagne il s'appelait
rabibocher ménard man que l'on appelle
naamani d'
unité grand rabbin de gérone en espagne
et il était sorti vainqueur d'une joute
oratoire
que l'on appelait une disputation cas
vus en 263 barcelone une des plus
célèbres disputation de l'histoire qu'on
appelle pour cette raison même la
disputation de barcelone
il avait été tellement brillant que le
roi a aimés avait d'une proclamé
vainqueur de cette joute oratoire
cela n'avait pas été du goût de
l'inquisition qui avait cherché des poux
dans la tête à rabin harman qui avait dû
s'exiler
c'était juste à la fin des croisades à
une époque où pendant toute cette
période où les croisés avaient occupé la
terre sainte et jérusalem cette ville
était interdite aux juifs donc c'est le
seul moment de l'histoire où
pratiquement il n'y a plus eu depuis de
présence juive à jérusalem
et la réimplantation des juifs à
jérusalem s'est faite par rabin harman
qui est venue de gérone avec ses
disciples pour s'installer à jérusalem
et quand il est arrivé dans cette ville
il a écrit une lettre à sa communauté de
gérone pour donner des nouvelles et pour
dire qu'ils étaient bien arrivés
il a écrit à peu près ceci j'ai une très
bonne nouvelle à vous annoncer
la terre d'israël est desséchée
désertique il n'y a pas un arbre il n'y
a pas un brin d'herbe ya pas une fleur
c'est une désolation
c'est une bonne nouvelle
en quoi ce que c'était une bonne
nouvelle
parce que la terre ne reconnaît pas nos
ennemis
et la terre attend le moment où nous
reviendrons pour ressusciter aussi avec
nous
il a fallu attendre la fin du 19e siècle
pour que ce miracle ait lieu
dix neuvième siècle
c'est un circuit très particulier
entre
la fin des croisades
et puis l'expédition de bonaparte on ne
revient en 1799
il ya eu une éclipse ou la terre
d'israël est devenu terra incognita
terre inconnue
tous les occidentaux
et
au moment de l'expédition de bonaparte
en orient
la terre d'israël était aussi étrangère
aux occidentaux que l'été l'afrique à
cette période
et l'expédition manqué de bonaparte a
provoqué un véritable engouement pour la
re découverte de la terre d'israël et
pendant toute la durée du 19e siècle
dénué de visiteurs occidentaux venant de
tous les pays de france d'angleterre
d'allemagne de russie des états unis par
l'europe c'était quand même occident et
autres lieux sont venus
visiter la terre d'israël pour des
motivations et pour des raisons
totalement différentes la majorité
venait pour des raisons religieuses
c'était le renouveau du pèlerinage en
terre sainte dans l'est sur les lieux
saints mais il y avait d'autres
motivations et avait
cartographe il y avait des scientifiques
il y avait des ornithologues il y avait
des géographes il y avait des historiens
il y avait des archéologues c'était le
début de toute la redécouverte de la
terre d'israël et il y avait également
des hommes de lettres
parmi eux quelques-uns de nos plus
célèbre homme de lettres à nous français
chateaubriand de les us en 12 et puis à
la fin du siècle
d'autres notamment un qui s'appelait
pierre loti caisses de son vrai nom
julien viaud qui était un officier de
marine d'origine protestante d'ailleurs
et a sauvé quand on me visiter la terre
d'israël à cette période ce n'était pas
une sinécure
on ne voyage pas en avion confortable en
quatre heures depuis paris
on ne circulait pas sur la terre
d'israël dans des autobus climatisé
confortable comme nous le faisons nous
et quand on venait ici dans cette noce
pays au 19ème siècle on risquait sa vie
et si l'on avait la chance de revenir
entier on avait beaucoup d' aventure a
raconté
si bien que beaucoup de ces pèlerins ou
de ses visiteurs qui sont venus en
nombre ce qu'on a pu en à cette époque
là la palestine
nous ont laissé des comptes rendus de
leur voyage et c'est très intéressant
parce que nous pouvons avoir une idée de
la manière dont ils ont vu la terre
d'israël à cette période c'était une
jolie 10 des hommes très différents
c'était des gens qui avaient des
motivations diverses
et qui ont donné qu'ils ont vu la terre
d'israël avec des yeux très très
différents
il ya au moins une chose sur laquelle
ils étaient tous d'accord mais tous
ceux que la terre d'israël était une
véritable désolation un véritable désert
une des rares femmes qui voyagent et en
israël à cette période là qui s'appelle
c'était une américaine il s'appelait
miss hamilton
écrivait au début de son récit de voyage
est saxons livre commence de la manière
suivante quelle désolation
non seulement le pays était désolé mais
il était abandonné
et je pense un homme comme pierre loti
qui à son retour de son voyage en
palestine
a écrit un livre qui s'appelle tout
simplement jérusalem qui vient d'être
réédité d'ailleurs les éditions du cerf
et
nous il commençait son livre de la
manière suivante au jerusalem quelque
splendeur dont ce nom qui va s'éteindre
dans cette ville qui est à l'agonie
et qu'une générations futures ne verra
même plus
jérusalem est est comme il le décrit
dans son livre à cette période une une
ville qui était à l'agonie
une ville qui était en train de mourir
ils pensaient
qu'il serait le dernier témoin de
jérusalem est que cette génération était
la dernière génération qui saurait qu'il
y avait eu à cet endroit une ville qui
s'appelait jérusalem jérusalem
pardonnez moi l'expression était en
train de crever dans l'indifférence la
plus générale personne ne se souciait de
la mort de jérusalem
je pense aussi à un autre personnage un
autre visiteur de cette période
c'était un pasteur suisse il s'appelait
félix bové
et lui est l inverse depuis un outil qui
croyait qu'il était un prophète de
malheur
mais au contraire était un homme de foi
et à la fin de son récit de voyage il
écrivait ceci
c'est de cette ce pays en gros j'ai pu
la citation exacte en tête c'est
beaucoup mieux dit que ce que je veux
dire là mais ce pays
est bien est un pays dans lequel il n'ya
plus d'habitants
les arabes ne l'ont pas véritablement
l'épousé dieu n'a permis à aucun de ces
peuples qui l'ont occupé tour à tour et
les sites les les byzantins les croisés
les arabes les ottomans et caetera
et dit dieu n'a permis aucun aucun de
ces peuples là de prendre racine et de
s'établir dans ce pays
est tien ce prix en réserve pour le
peuple qui le possédera un jour le
peuple d'israël
par conséquent la terre dit sereine et
est devenue une terre désolée
et lorsque ont éclaté ces programmes
dont je parlais tout à l'heure
à la fin du 19e siècle et au début du
20e siècle en europe centrale et en
europe de l'est
un certain nombre de ces jeunes gens qui
subissaient ces persécutions se sont dit
quand tu as quitté l'europe pour
nous vendre ou
et bien faisons le choix le pari de
revenir dans la terre d'israël
il faut savoir que pendant les deux
mille ans d'exil
depuis la destruction du temple jusqu'à
nos jours il y a toujours eu une
présence juive en israël
n'a pas toujours été très très
nombreuses la communauté juive n'a pas
été toujours très nombreuses il ya
toujours eu des juifs dans ce pays
jamais les juifs n'ont abandonné l'idée
de revenir dans ce pays et ceux qui le
pouvaient le faisait venez s'établir ici
dans cette terre ce qu'était la terre
promise pour eux et il ya même des
familles ici qu'ils sont cons qui ont
continué à exister à vivre de génération
en génération danse rit sans aucune
interruption jusqu'à nos jours
seulement ceux qui venaient dans ce pays
là
venez dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles puisque ce pays et est
désertique il était désolé et les
conditions de vie étaient évidemment
très très difficile
et c'était souvent des personnes âgées
les hommes âgés qui venait dans ce pays
non pas pour y vivre mais pourrait
mourir
et être enterré dans le pays d'israël de
manière à être si j'ose dire aux
premières loges conviendrait la
résurrection des morts
et en 1882
une première
il peut imprimer ou deux jeunes gens
c'était l'époque où la communauté juive
avait grandi considérablement à
jérusalem est déjà la majorité disons à
la fin du 19e siècle en 1882 la majorité
des habitants de jérusalem était juif
j'avais à peu près 7000 habitants à
jérusalem à cette période là aujourd'hui
oui il ya des plusieurs centaines de
milliers on est bien loin de cette
période
et c'était ce qu'on appelait le
mouvement de sortie des murailles les
murailles de la ville de la ville était
trop petit et on a commencé à venir
s'établir en dehors de ces fameuses
murail
un groupe de jeunes gens est arrivé de
russie
pour non plus venu mourir dans ce pays
mais pour vive et faire revivre la terre
d'israël
ils ont pu y avait plus le nom de b you
ce qui est
ainsi d'un verset du prophète isaïe
beth israel
nacoulma vénale et
maison d'israël vont nous aimons tant
dans la terre du sillon sous-entendu bon
c'est l'app se rappelle la première alia
la première immigration la première
monte c'est le début d'une période
nouvelle qui était celui de la
résurrection de la terre d'israël la
résurrection des ossements desséchés
laventure débile ou a été un échec
et n'ont pas réussi parce qu'ils
n'avaient aucune expérience de la terre
aucune expérience de l'agriculture et la
plupart d'entre eux sauveteurs fut
finalement retourné en russie mais
l'élan était donné l'exemple été donnée
et quelques années plus tard au début du
20e siècle avec l'aide de mécènes tels
que les barons de rothschild ou d'autres
et la fondation de ce qui deviendra lé
là le fonds de rachat de la terre
d'israël qui avait été créée par
théodore herzl à bâle en 1897
le le
2 les premières des premiers villages
agricoles juifs se sont installés dans
ce pays
ils l'ont fait comme cela nous a été
rappelé aujourd'hui
sur des terres qui était un culte
des terres qu'ils ont acheté à prix d'or
de la part défendu ou de cheikh arabe
qui n'avait que faire de ces terrains
marécageuse de ces terrains sablonneux
qui était totalement impropres à la
culture
et
ces gens là qui ont vendu à bon prix aux
immigrants juifs
la terre d'israël contrairement à ce que
dit la propagande les juifs nos chats
ces personnes de leur terre vous pensez
bien le pays d'israël était sous la
domination des ottomans à cette période
là et vous pensez bien que les autorités
ottomanes n'aurait jamais permis que des
juifs excuses de leurs terres des arabes
pour s'installer à leur place et la
propagande arabe sur laquelle les arabes
ont été chassés de l'offre de leurs
terres par les méchants juifs qui sont
venues d'europe c'est une légende qui ne
tient absolument pas la route qui nous
inquiète absolument absurde
et le miracle s'est produit
après avoir subi de nombreux échecs ses
terres incultes on commençait à produire
il ya eu ça nous a été rappelé aussi
aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens qui ont dû sacrifier
logis pour faire revivre la terre
d'israël
les gens qui n'avaient aucune expérience
de l'agriculture qui se sont formées à
partir de rien sur le terrain est ce que
ni les templiers dont il nous a été
parler ni les arabes ni les croisais
n'avait réussi à faire refaire revivre
cette terre désertique et bien comme on
dit les pionniers juifs la terre nous a
reconnus et comme l'avait bien vu rabin
et ramène armani d' bien lorsque
le peuple d'israël est revenu dans son
pays la terre s'est réveillé un peu
comme la belle au bois dormant de que
des contes de fées c'est un véritable
conte de fées que la résurrection de
cette terre
et comme je disais tout à l'heure
la terre d'israël et de revenus fertile
on a ici affaire à une des crises
agriculture les plus florissantes qui
soit et comme l'avait annoncé le
prophète isaïe
dans ce temps là autant de la fin là le
pays d'israël remplira le monde entier
de ses fruits et vous pouvez trouver des
produits de l'agriculture d'israël
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier
les rabbins ont dit qu'en ce verset
s'accomplira c'était au moyen âge qui a
eu ce commentaire
quand ce verset s'accomplira et quand le
peuple d'israël remplira le monde entier
de ses fruits ce sera le signe que le
monsieur est à la porte
et nous voyons aujourd'hui ce miracle se
réalise et ça c'est le deuxième miracle
d'israël après la résurrection de la
langue
le
troisième miracle ou d'israël
c'est la résurrection d'une nation
israélienne d'un peuple israélien
nous visons ici une situation absolument
unique au monde
quelqu'un tout à l'heure à tam le
faisais la réflexion
dix ans ici c'est un pays on se rend
compte que c'est un pays internationale
la personne qui disait ça ne croyez pas
si bien dire
les juifs qui sont rassemblés dans ce
pays viennent aujourd'hui de 120 nations
différentes
et le problème c'est comment des gens
aussi différents de langue de tradition
de culture et qui finalement n'ont qu'un
lien ténu qui les unit les uns aux
autres leur appartenance au peuple juif
et pour une minorité d'entre la religion
en juillet
comment ces gens ont ils pu former une
seule nation sur la terre d'israël
et ça ça a été le problème du
gouvernement provisoire d'israël au
moment de la guerre d'indépendance en
1948 au lendemain de la première et la
deuxième guerre mondiale
et au moment où l'état d'israël a été
proclamé le 15 mai 1948 sont afflué
d'europe en particulier des camps de la
mort
où les survivants de la shoah avaient
continué à être parqués depuis 1945
jusqu'en 1948 par les autorités des pays
occidentaux soi disant démocratique il
ne pouvait pas sortir des camps de
concentration dans lesquelles il avait
été interné par les nazis pendant
plusieurs années ils sont restés
prisonniers dans ces camps là
c'était
quelque chose d'épouvantable
et les anglais en particulier ferme
hermétiquement les portes de la terre
d'israël à ces rescapés de la shoah dont
au demeurant plus personne ne voulait
personne ne voulait les accueillir
personne ne voulait les recevoir
et lorsque l'état d'israël a été hacké a
été créée en 1948 les premiers bateaux
on a porté les immigrants depuis
l'europe depuis les camps de
concentration nazis afflué sur les quais
du port de haïfa le pays était en guerre
ils étaient assaillis par cette armée
arabe et il n'y avait pas possibilité
d'accueillir ces gens dans des
conditions décentes alors on est
s'empiler sur les quais du port de haïfa
où il était d'ailleurs bombardé par
l'aviation égyptienne
c'était une véritable cour de miracle
s'était
assemblé terrain assemblage hétéroclite
de gens dont certains étaient de
véritables cadavres ambulants qui
arrivait dans des conditions absolument
épouvantable il avait tout perdu il
n'avait plus d'espérance comme nous
disent nous disait le texte desquelles
tout à l'heure il était vraiment
semblable à ces ossements desséchés qui
sortait des tombeaux des nations et
jamais la prophétie des et qu'elle n'a
été plus actuel que pendant cette
période les premiers mois qui ont suivi
la fin du mandat britannique la
proclamation de l'état d'israël en 1948
et devant cette situation cet afflux qui
faisait qu'en l'espace de quelques mois
la population d'israël a doublé dans ce
pays la population juive adoubé dans ce
pays alors que le pays était en guerre
et qu'il était dans une situation
économique dramatique
le gouvernement provisoire d'israël
présidée par monsieur ben gourion
a fait venir des spécialistes venant
sociologie des états unis
et ils leur ont confié le mandat suivant
prenez contact avec tous ces immigrants
qui arrivent
essentiellement d'europe mais également
des pays arabes que j'arrive aussi
démuni de tout parce qu'ils ont été
leurs biens tous leurs biens ont été
confisqués dans les pays arabes avant
qu'il n'en soit expulsé
et dites-nous en combien de temps vu
l'expérience que vous avez du
melting-pot américain combien de temps
estimez-vous nécessaires pour que de ce
conglomérat de gens qui viennent de tous
les pays du monde puisse naître une
nation israélienne
et ces sociologues ont fait une enquête
qui a duré environ trois semaines ils
sont interrogés les uns les autres enfin
ils ont fait des enquêtes très poussées
et trois soeurs au bout de trois
semaines enquête ils ont donné leurs
conclusions gouvernement israélien ils
ont dit à peu près ceci compte tenu de
l'expérience qui est la nôtre états unis
compte tenu de l'état dans lesquelles
ces gens ici arrive compte tenu de
l'état dans lequel votre pays se trouve
estimant que pour que naisse une nation
israélienne à partir de ce conglomérat
hétéroclite de gens il faudra plusieurs
générations
le gouvernement israélien était atterré
c'était beaucoup trop plusieurs
générations eh bien l'état d'israël
aurait depuis longtemps disparu c'était
donc la mort programmée de l'état
d'israël
et les socios ont répondu écoutez nous
sommes désolés mais ne pouvons pas vous
dire autre chose c'est
nos prévisions les plus optimistes sont
là pouvons parler dire autre chose que
cela
à peine dix ans après en 1956
peu après la première guerre du sinaï
ces sociologues sont revenus en israël
pour voir où en était le processus
d'intégration qu'ils avaient étudié huit
ans plus tôt
et où ils ont fait la une enquête à
nouveau de trois semaines ils ont revu
les mêmes personnes ils ont vu d'autres
bref ils ont fait un travail extrêmement
sérieux et au bout de trois semaines ils
ont donné leurs conclusions au
gouvernement israélien ils ont dit ceci
nous sommes heureux de vous dire que
nous nous sommes trompés dans nous
faisons nos prévisions et que à peine
dix ans après la création de l'état
d'israël et après l'arrivée de cette
vague d'immigration sans précédent il
existe aujourd'hui une nation
israélienne
mais cela ne pouvait expliquer que par
un miracle
et ça c'est le troisième miracle
d'israël que ces gens ont réussi à
s'intégrer au
soyons clair ça ne s'est pas toujours
facile de passer d'une manière facile il
a eu des tensions il ya eu des
oppositions
il ya eu de graves problèmes qui ont dû
être résolus mais ils ont été résolues
et il continue à être résolu et chaque
fois qu'une nouvelle vague d'immigration
qu'arrivent les russes les éthiopiens
maintenant les français ça pose toujours
des problèmes
c'est pas quelque chose qui se fait
harmonieusement mais les problèmes sont
surmontées parce qu'il ya un miracle que
ton coup c'est le miracle de
rassemblement de ses ossements desséchés
d'israël qui viennent des 120 tombeau
des nations qui sont dispersés sur toute
la surface de la terre
le quatrième et dernier miracle c'est le
miracle de l'armée
l'armée
la création d'une armée juive
depuis 135 après jésus-christ c'est à
dire la deuxième révolte juive que l'on
appelle la période la révolte de bar
kokhba le peuple d'israël a cessé d'être
un peuple combattant
et
cette réalité
eh bien elle s'est réalisée dans
l'histoire
parce que de la même manière que l'on
interdisait aux juifs d'être des paysans
on leur interdisait aussi d'être des
soldats
ont considéré les juifs comme étant des
pleutres
des lâches des couloirs
qui ne savaient pas ce bac qui ne savait
pas se défendre
et très souvent au moment des massacres
des pogroms les juifs se sont laissé
massacrer comme les brebis qu'on mène à
la boucherie non pas parce qu'ils
étaient plus lâches que les autres mais
parce qu'ils n'avaient strictement aucun
moyen de se défendre
et cela a donné lieu à cette idée à
cette légende que le peuple d'israël
était un peuple qui ne savait pas se
battre
non seulement il ne savait pas se battre
mais c'est un peuple de judas un peuple
de traîtres
et avoir des soldats juifs dans son
armée c'était risquer d'avoir un coup de
poignard dans le dos la part de ces jeux
et l'on sait combien cette légende
dralha
sera aura la vie dure puisque au moment
de l'affairé dreyfus en france c'est
exactement ce que l'on a reproché au
capitaine dreyfus d'être un traître
qu'il n'était pas
et ce n'est qu'après la révolution
française
que l'on a accepté après avoir donner
l'égalité des droits aux juifs avec
beaucoup de réticence et avec beaucoup
de suspicion de permettre aux juifs de
porter les armes
il y avait
en russie que tu es un des pays les plus
antisémites d'europe au début du 20e
siècle et à la fin du 19e
il y avait un jeune homme s'appelait
leur chef rebelle d'or
et ce jeune homme
était juif
il connaissait la légende qui faisait
que qui disait que les juifs étaient des
gens qui ne savaient pas se battre il a
décidé de démontrer au jour aux russes
que les juifs n'étaient pas ce qu'il
pensait il s'est engagé dans l'armée du
tsar
et il est devenu officier à cause de sa
bravoure
il a participé à la guerre russo
japonaise et au
siège de port arthur où il a perdu un
bras
et à cause d'un acte de bravoure sans
précédent il a été le premier officier
juif qui a été décoré par la tsarine
qui était très antisémite au demeurant
c'était l'époque de du sionisme débuts
du sionisme et des amants de sion
et youssef troupel d'or qui était un
officier de carrière est venu
s'installer en israël
à l'époque où
la vision de théodore hessel était celle
d'un état pacifique
théodore et recel s'imaginer que les
juifs allaient apporter aux arabes
présents dans ce pays les bienfaits de
la civilisation et que ces derniers
allaient on leur en être reconnaissants
et que par conséquent il y avait de
toute manière un des liens de parenté
entre juifs et arabes n'étaient ils pas
tous fils d'abraham n'était il pas des
sémites n'avait-il pas une langue qui
était plus ou moins une langue commune
alors ils pensaient qu'ils allaient être
accueillis à bras ouverts les juifs
qu'ils allaient revenir dans ce pays sa
lettre accueillie à bras ouverts par les
arabes il a fallu rapidement déchanté et
notamment lorsque les arabes ou vu que
ces terres qu'ils avaient vendu à à
à ces juifs étaient en train de
reprendre vie ils on veut essayer de
récupérer et les premiers clashs les
premiers heurts ont éclaté entre les
communautés juives qui s'est installée
dans ce pays et les arabes
et les juifs qui n'avait aucune
expérience militaire ne savait pas
comment s'y prendre il y avait ils ont
essayé de mettre des gardes mais ça
n'allait pas très loin et quand youssef
troupel d'or est arrivée dans ce pays
lui qui était un militaire de carrière
il a bien compris que il fallait créer
une armée juive ne serait pas possible
de créer un état indépendant dans ce
pays sans avoir à se battre
et il a été celui qui a créer l'embryon
de la ii
de l'armée d'israël il a créé un corps
ont appuyé le chaume rim les gardiens
qui était calqué sur les cosaques russe
il en avait pratiquement le costume il
en avait les armes bref il employait
toutes les techniques des cosaques russe
sftp d'or était lui-même russe
et lorsqu'a éclaté la première guerre
mondiale il a réussi à obtenir des
anglais la création d'un corps qui est
de 2,2 juifs du pays d'israël qui devait
lutter à côté des armées alliées
les britanniques n'avaient aucune
confiance dans les valeurs militaires
des juifs ils ont refusé de créer ce
corps de volontaires juifs et aux sacs
poubelles d'or a dû insister insisté
finalement des anglais ont accepté de
créer un corps de ravitaillement qu'on
appelait les muletiers de sion zion mood
cops
et
ce corps des muletiers de sion commandé
par yossef trompette d'or en personne
s'est illustré sur la le front de
gallipoli en 1916
et ça a été le début de l'année juive
je passe parce que j'avais beaucoup pas
dire là dessus
mais le 15 mai 1948 au moment où l'état
d'israël était proclamée à tel aviv
toutes les chambres d'hôtel étaient
occupés on ne pouvait plus trouver une
seule chambre d'hôtel de libre toutes
les chambres d'hôtel étaient retenus par
des journalistes qui étaient venus du
monde entier
pour assister à la proclamation de
l'état d'israël qui allait naître
et ses chambres elle était retenue pour
trois jours pas un de plus
pourquoi trois jours
parce que
chez tous les grands stratèges du monde
entier en particulier
le général montgomery
une
s'était illustré pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
trois jours c'était le temps que l'on
donné à l'état d'israël pour naître et
pour mourir
montgomery et ceux qui étaient autour de
lui avait affirmé que les six cent mille
juifs qui se trouvait dans le pays
d'israël confronté à 40 millions
d'arabes
cette arme est haram armée à la moderne
encadrés par des officiers occidentaux
par d'anciens nazis
entraîner d'une manière
disons classique ou chose militaire
ne ferait qu'une bouchée
de cette milice juive qui avait été créé
à partir de rien qui était mal armés qui
étaient mal entraînés qui était mal
comment dépenser ton et qui par
conséquent ne pouvait pas tenir plus de
trois jours en face des armées arabes
trois jours connaître et pour mourir
et au bout de trois jours
non seulement israël était né mais il
n'était pas mort
hélas une série de miracles ont commencé
à se produire ce peuple d'israël qui
n'avait pas été qui n'avait pas combattu
depuis l'époque de la prise de jérusalem
par titus et la deuxième révolte de bar
kokhba a fait des exploits militaires
mais avec les avec l'aide de dieu je
suis très simplement deux exemples parmi
des dizaines et des dizaines d'autres
que je pourrais prendre
le premier c'est nous sera demain au
regard des neet source du jourdain je
demanderai à réel de nous emmener voir
le l'entrée du kibboutz degania
le premier des kibboutz d'israël
est ce qui vous était gagnant
dès que le
l'état d'israël a été proclamée a été
attaqué par les syriens qui descendait
des hauteurs du golan nous étions
et la nuit qui précède l attaque le
commandant de la place s'est rendu à
l'état major général lâcheuse alem ai
dit voilà je vais être attaquer demain
par des chars syriens il me faut des
armes antichars
et le commandant en chef lui a dit ceci
non seulement je ne vais pas te donner
d'armes antichars mais je te prendre les
quelques unes que tu as
les malheurs nous sommes perdus c'est
nous condamner à mort que nous nous
prendre les quelques rasam antichar que
nous avons
qu'est ce que nous allons faire
et le commandant chef gas holdings leur
a dit eh bien quand les chats approchons
vous laisserez escalader les parapets
des tranchées vous sortirez des
tranchées vous jetterez dessus avec des
bouteilles d'essence
c'est la seule chose que vous pouvez
faire
le commandant de la place de dégagnac
est retourné avec ses instructions là et
de fait le lendemain matin l'attak
syrienne qui disposé de chars français
au demeurant
s'est déclenchée et l'on peut voir
encore le premier char qui a tenté
d'escalader une parade le parapet de la
tranchée et un enfant de 14 ans est
sorti de cette tranchée avec deux
bouteilles d'essence sur dans ce schéma
se jeter sur le chat et le chara a pris
feu quand ils ont vu la détermination
des défenseurs les syriens ont fait
demi-tour ne sont plus jamais revenus
et le kibboutz a été sauvé tout le front
du nord a été sauvée
vous avez peut-être vu tout à l'heure
quand nous avons traversé tibériade de
la grande place la place centrale la
place de la poste vient un monument avec
un petit canon
ce qu'elle ce canon date de l'époque de
napoléon
et pour cette raison on l'appelle un
napoléon chick le petit napoléon
c'était à peu près toute l'artillerie
disposer l'état d'israël en 1948 - de
l'attak arabe
il y avait sur le fond du nord dans la
région de tibériade deux de ces cas non
seulement
des canons qui datait de l'époque de
napoléon vous imaginez pour lutter
contre des armes modernes
et ses canons étaient postés sur les
hauteurs qui dominent tibériade au
moment où une colonne blindée composé de
chars syriens et irakiens ça a franchi
le jourdain
et lorsque ces forces blindées son
talent sont approchés de de tibériade un
premier obus ont été tirés et ce premier
taureau obus est tombé sur la tempe
d'état-major hutu d'état-major ennemis
étaient rassemblés tous les officiers
supérieurs ont été tuées
et l'armée a été décapité la filmer tour
le deuxième que l'homme est arrivée peu
de temps après et un deuxième but a été
tiré
il est tombé sur un camion d'essence
qu'ils se trouvaient au milieu de la
colonne blindée
nous camion d'essence a pris feu le feu
s'est communiqué à tous les chats qui
était dans la dans la rangée et tous les
chars ont tout brûlé les uns après les
autres et la colonne blindée a fait
d'habitude
ça c'est quelques-uns des miracles qui
se sont accomplis pendant cette guerre
d'indépendance qui était la plus dure
des guerres d'israël en l'espace de
quelques mois israël non seulement a
réussi à survivre non seulement il a
réussi à repousser ses ennemis mais il a
réussi à agrandir son propre territoire
de semblables me raconte eu lieu aussi
pendant la guerre des six jours j'en ai
parlé l'autre joue pendant la guerre du
kippour qui a été une guerre où
logiquement israël aurait dû être
détruits notamment sur le front nord sur
le front du golan et lorsque les les
israéliens quand j'ai totalement pris
par surprise
n'avait qu'une poignée de chars poser à
une marée de chars comme on n'en a
jamais vu dans l'histoire qui déferlait
sur le golan
cette poignée de char israélien a été
balayée et en bas dans la vallée les
réserves israéliennes étaient en train
de se concentrer ce qui voulait dire
qu'il n'y avait plus aucun obstacle
pour que les syriens ne dévale du
plateau du golan et ne fondent sur les
réserves qui était en train de
s'organiser qui n'était pas encore
opérationnel n'était pas encore en état
de combattre ça veut dire que c'était le
massacre assuré c'était la destruction
de l'état de l'armée d'israël assuré et
par conséquent de l'état d'israël
et lorsqu'ils sont arrivés sur le bord
du plateau et chars syriens d'une
manière inexpliquée ont fait demi tour
et ont permis aux réserves israélien de
s'organiser dre de préparer et ensuite
d'exécuter la contre attaque contre
attaque victorieuse
le commandant de la 7e division blindée
si rien n'a été fait prisonnier pendant
cette contre attaque
les officiers israéliens qui ont
interrogé sous commandant en chef
aujourd'hui mais une chose qu'on
comprend pas vous êtes arrivé dans les
premiers jours de la taxe sur les bords
du plateau il y avait rien dedans vous
n'avez aucun obstacle et vous avez filmé
tour
pourquoi on comprend pas
et cet officier a répondu j'aurais voulu
vous y voir
il y avait devant nous une troupe
d'hommes en blanc des milliers et des
milliers de milliers d'hommes en blanc
qui était là devant nous et une grande
main gigantesque qui nous a fait signe
de faire demi tour
et ce témoignage là il est attesté de
très très nombreux source
nombreux sont ceux qui ont un client qui
témoigne de cette réalité là
voyez vous la survivance d'israël
l'existence de cette armée comme disait
tout à l'heure le père d'un nadal à 4
exactement ma daf et remet la plus
morale de toute l'histoire humaine et
bien c'est le quatrième miracle dit
sereine et israéliens sont fiers de leur
armée ils ont des raisons de l'être
4 miracle
la langue la résurrection de la langue
résurrection de la terre la résurrection
du peuple et la résurrection de l'armée
or quand nous regardons l'histoire
d'israël
nous constatons que ces miracles
ne sont pas unique dans l'histoire
d'israël ce n'est pas simplement à notre
époque que de tels miracles se sont
produits
mais nous retrouvons le même type de
miracle à l'époque de jésus est par
exemple ou à l'époque des macchabées
et
c'est donc ici chaque fois que le peuple
d'israël est revenu dans son pays que
c'est me raconte eu lieu
et en même temps quand peuple d'israël a
été dans son pays un message est sorti
du peuple d'israël vers les nations
d'or de la première époque que j'ai
évoqué ce qu'on appelle l'époque du
premier temple
un message est sorti d'israël vers les
nations
c'est l'écriture ce que les chrétiens
appelle improprement l'ancien testament
lors de l'ipo du deuxième temple un
deuxième message est sorti d'israël vers
les nations c'est le nouveau testament
et voilà que pour la 3 troisième fois
dans l'histoire
les miracles et même irak se reproduise
est ce que cela veut dire qu'un
troisième message va sortir d'israël
vers les nations je crois qu'on a lieu
de le penser
et quel sera ce troisième message et
bien c'est l'accomplissement des
prophéties
c'est la venue du messie celle annonce
des temps messianiques
et on pourrait se demander est ce sera
ma conclusion
en quoi est ce que en tant que chrétiens
occidentaux
nous sommes concernés par la
résurrection des ossements desséchés
d'israël
nous sommes concernés tout simplement
parce que
la résurrection d'israël est le gage de
notre propre rédemption
ne seront pas sauvés sans le peuple
d'israël et nous serons sauvés par la
rédemption du peuple d'israël ne sont
pas sauvés par le peuple d'israël mais
nous serons sauvés par la rédemption que
dieu donne est en train de donner au
peuple d'israël et qui d'israël se
répandra d'israël vers les nations pour
qu elles aussi puissent connaître le
salut eschatologique puisse connaître le
salut messianique été annoncée par les
prophètes c'est un mets très nombreuses
qui avait vu le prophète qui sera en
bénédiction pour toutes les nations
alors s'accomplira la prophétie qui
avait été fait à bram je bénirai ce qui
te béniront je maudirai ce qui te
maudiront toutes les nations de la terre
seront bénis en toi voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire ce soir bonsoir à tout
le monde
le sujet que vous demandez d'abord
d'état sujet très vaste
je vais tenter je vais essayer de
décrire un peu les grandes étapes de la
création d'israël depuis 100 ans bien
entendu cette histoire de 100 enfants ne
se passe pas sans événement et sans
guerre et sans lutte mais avant de
commencer il faut bien comprendre que la
création d' état d'israël en 1948 est en
fait un des événements de l'histoire du
peuple juif qui a commencé il ya trois
mille huit cents ans
et comme vous le savez le peuple juif a
été exilé il y environ deux mille ans
par les romains et n'a jamais perdu sa
foi absolue dans le retour d'israël tel
qu'il est décrit
dans un scoop qui a été donnée à 2801
par les prophètes d'israël et qui dit
simplement que viendra un moment où le
dieu d'israël ramènera son peuple de
l'exil et c'est ce qui se passe comment
ça devait se passer même lorsqu'on est
très très versé dans l'étude et la
lecture du canard inquiète donc la bible
hébraïque et bien souvent les
professions étaient donnés de façon
assez difficile à comprendre
cela semble souvent comme une espèce de
métaphores d'allégories mais en fait les
choses se passent exactement
comme elles sont décrites et on les
comprend mieux maintenant si
je vais m'intéresser maintenant à la
période de 100 ans
des 100 dernières années et bien en fait
il faut bien comprendre que le lac
reconstruction de l'état d'israël
a commencé de façon pratique en 1917
qu'est ce qui se passe en 1917 l' empire
ottoman et vaincus et les puissances
donc qu'ils ont vaincus l'empiré ottoman
entreprennent de dpc cet empire qui
était déjà en déliquescence empire qui
s'étend des d'ailleurs très loin jusqu'à
en fait l'afrique du nord les balkans et
c est en particulier une région qui
s'appelait depuis 2000 ans la palestine
qui est en fait
la terre d'israël on trouve des sources
par exemple très intéressant dans le
larousse de 1923 et etc où on décrit la
palestine comme le pays des juifs là
terrain la terre promise etc il faut
tout de suite précisé que le mot
palestine a été donné c'est un mot en
fait grec palestina qui était donné en
135 par l' empire par l'empereur pardon
adrien et ce mot palestine a est en fait
la traduction grecque du mot philistine
le mot philistine veut dire en fait le
pays défie liste de quoi s'agit-il
mophie liste en hébreu plichta signifie
envahisseurs c'est à dire que les
romains en essayant de d'éradiquer le
lien entre la terre d'israël eretz
israël et le peuple juif a d'ailleurs
entre guillemets rebaptisé le nom de
jérusalem est également adonné
à la terre d'israël op des juifs à la
terre promise c'est taira le nom d'une
contrée qui étaient occupées justement
par des ennemis du peuple juif comme
l'appellent les philistins doux vénétie
philistins je répète plichta
envahisseurs et bien en fait ils
venaient
des îles de la mer egée et auparavant de
l'île de crète en fait c'étaient des
populations de corsair de pirate de
brigands qui s'étaient installés sur la
côte ouest ashkelon ashdod
gaza du pays d'israël et ses philistins
qui était donc des envahisseurs donc en
fait des européens ont créé énormément
de problèmes au peuple juif je remonte
maintenant à la fois autant de avram est
au temps du roi david donc nous revenons
maintenant de milan le peuple juif est
exilé
on a par en particulier
d'abord des documents historiques et
puis on a un monument qui s'appelle
l'arc de triomphe de titus ou
comble du ridicule pour l'unesco on voit
très bien les juifs porter les
ustensiles du temple qui se trouve
d'ailleurs
dans les caves du vatican mais ce n'est
pas le sujet
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé 2001 les
juifs donc ont prié pour revenir at
sillonne à sion le pays d'israël et en
1917 donc nous revenons un petit peu
notre empire ottoman l'empiré ottoman et
démantelé et parallèlement à ça il y à
une déclaration qui s'appelle
déclaration balfour par lesquels par
laquelle les anglais
s'engage à permettre l'instauration d'un
foyer national juif fnj en palestine
historique
différentes résolutions sont ensuite
prises en particulier la décision finale
est entériné sur la proposition d'un
notaire par la conférence de san remo en
1922 qui confie à l'angleterre et à la
france le soin de gérer la région
que nous appelons la palestine
historique c'est à dire si vous voyez la
société cartes en fait voici l'état
d'israël d'aujourd'hui et cette partie
là qui était en fait destiné
et offrit au futur foyer national juif
donc de permettre
l'instauration
d'un état juif et c'était donc le mandat
qu'ils avaient été données aux anglais
les français
recevant comme mandat le fait de le fait
de gérer ce qui va devenir ensuite liban
la syrie et l'irak nous allons bien
entendu traiter de la partie qui
avait-elle où israël en 1923
bien qu'en fait la décision d'allocation
au peuple juif de ce territoire qui
englobe en fait la jordanie
d'aujourd'hui cette décision était
enterrée par la société des nations et
plus tard d'ailleurs une façon d'une
autre par l'onu revenons en 1923 le
ministre des colonies whist britannique
winston churchill décide pour des
raisons
purement
politiques qui sont d'ailleurs toujours
valable d'une façon ou d'une autre
aujourd'hui ne sais pas si on aura le
temps d'aborder ce point est bien décidé
de confisquer trois quarts du terrain
qu'ils avaient été alloués donc au
peuple juif dans le premier plan de
partition
les réseaux sont longues expliqué ce
n'est pas le moment maintenant d'y
rentrer mais ça pourrait faire l'objet
éventuellement
d'une d'autres explications du type qui
sont très intéressante également quoi
qu'il en soit ce partage de 1922 et les
différents plans de partition qui ont
été ensuite su géré
par la société nationaux venus n'ont
jamais été accepté par les pays arabes
nous entendons par pays arabes les pays
arabes qui existe à l'époque
essentiellement l'egypte l'arabie
saudite et cetera la jordanie n'existait
pas à l'école elle était montée en 1927
et il ya une opposition du monde arable
en fait à la présence même du peuple
juif sur sa terre ancestrale
donc arrêtons nous là pour l'instant
donc le fait de
l'institution de ce qui allait devenir
en 1948 au terme du mandat qui avaient
été confiés par les organisations
internationales
allant à l'angleterre eh bien
c'est se plante c'est plein de partage
n'ont jamais été acceptées et d'ailleurs
jusqu'à aujourd'hui par les pays du
monde arabe bien entendu certains me
posant la question et les pastilles inde
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle les
palestiniens
peuple qui n'existe pas on va en parler
tout de suite et qui a été en fait une
invention
de evgueni primakov et du kgb dans les
années 1970 c'est à dire calque de trois
ans après la guerre des six jours on
entrera tout de suite pour essayer
justement de délégitimiser le droit du
peuple juif à sa terre et de transformer
le peuple juif et les isréliens en
colons de leurs propres terres
donc nous revient pas en arrière les
plans différents temps partition n'ont
jamais été acceptées par le monde aura
plus qu'aujourd'hui et en 1948 david ben
gourion décide
de la création de l'état d'israël c'est
à dire le retour d'un pouvoir juif sur
la terre ancestrale
d'israël après 2000 ans d'exil c'est
quelque chose de phénoménal
d'extraordinaire qui n'a pas son pareil
dans l'histoire bien entendu déjà avant
donc les pays arabes alentours font la
guerre israël cinq pays arabes en 1948
attaque israël et israël et vainqueur et
à ce moment là ils se basent josas
intéressante c'est que
tout est bousculé et en particulier la
jordanie occupe une partie donc
de de la rive gauche du jourdain qui
s'appelle la journée la jante la judée
samarie dont nous allons parler qui va
en gros de la vallée de jeu est réel
jusqu'à la vie de beersheva en englobant
inattendu gijon est en fait bien entendu
au sein de jérusalem et la jordanie
également en 1948 occupe la partie est
de jérusalem
et à ce moment là et pendant donc ces
quelques années ses 19 ans la jordanie
va occuper de façon illégale
la judée samarie
tout seul on parlait tout de suite et
il faut signaler jérusalem est comme
vous le savez et
jérusalem d'ailleurs qui avait qui
devait avoir un statut
différent qui n'avait pas été décidé
d'ailleurs par l'onu en attendant de
voir comment les choses allaient se
passer quoi qu'il en soit en 1948 la
jordanie occupent illégalement
par agression militaire la judée samarie
qui était en fait pratiquement vide
d'habitants
et s'y installe en fin de compte
l'occupation de la jordanie n'a jamais
été reconnue par
aucune nation sauf l'angleterre la
perfide albion et le pakistan et en
particulier aucune grande nation et de
même n'a pas été reconnu par les pays
alentour pourquoi la jordanie est un
pays en fait artificielle qui était donc
encouragés par les gens de parler les
britanniques et
qui était en fait tu maîtrises méprisé
pardon par la dynastie wahhabite
d'arabie saoudite
toute cette période
de 1948 2107 en fait tu vois d'une part
la croissance y serait la construction
d'israël dans tous les domaines mais
voit également une guérilla menée par
les forces jordaniennes la légion
jordanienne sans arrêt sur les villages
juifs et sur jérusalem
nous arrivons maintenant 1967 en 1967
trois pays arabe la jordanie de nouveau
l'egypte et la syrie attaque de nouveau
israël armes et surarmé avec un
équipement militaire soviétique très
important et grâce à dieu
israël
riposte est donc
réussi à repousser les attaques de ces
trois pays en leur en leur imposant des
dommages très grave il sera intéressant
d'ailleurs de tout va un petit peu parlé
de la guerre des six jours mais ce n'est
pas le sujet central de ce soir qu'est
ce qui se passe en 67 israël
conquiert la partie est de jérusalem en
particulier à ville ville où il était
interdit aux juifs d'y pénétrer et en
particulier devant l'accès au mont du
temple et au mur occidental et la judée
samarie
donc revenons à la carte donc nous avons
ici nous avions donc toute cette partie
là plus ou moins qui représente on va
parler tout de suite 20 % de l'état
d'israël actuel et qui est libéré et
également jose alem vous essayez une
carte qui est plus en détail où on voit
que la judée samarie représente en fait
une arête montagneuse qui domine la
plaine et ne verront également quelle
est l'importance donc en 67 il serait
elle contient la judée samarie et cela
qu'est ce qui se passe du point de vue
du droit international
et bien comme vous le savez tous dès
l'instant où un pays agressé riposte et
conquiert le territoire de l'ennemi et
bien ce territoire devient le sien c'est
le droit de la guerre c'est laurent
internationale on a comme exemple des
dizaines et dizaines d'exemples prenons
l'exemple de la france que vous savez
l'alsace a été conquis occupé par l'apa
par la france après la défaite de
l'allemagne et les choses maintenant je
ne crois pas qu'aujourd'hui les gens que
je connaisse qui habite l'alsace pour
puisse prétendre ou que même la zac
puisse prétendre que l'alsace est
tellement en l'occurrence la judée
samarie n'a jamais appartenait la nage
au dessin mari pour deux raisons à la
jordanie pour deux raisons premièrement
parce qu'elle était une occupante
illégale et que deuxièmement la judée
samarie faisait partie de tous les plans
de partitions
sauf celui de 1947 tout plein de
partitions comme je dis précédemment qui
avait été en fait repousser et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui par les pires donc
le la possession de la judée samarie par
l'état d'israël est en fait conforme au
droit international
je ne voudrais pas
rentrer trop dans le détail mais vous
avez énormément de littérature en
particulier anglo saxon de professeur de
droit anglo saxon qui explique très très
bien ce qui s'est passé et en
particulier donc le droit d'israël à sa
terre et en fait il n'y a aucun
prétendant sérieux à la judée samarie
qui pose un gros problème à beaucoup de
nations pour différentes raisons bien
donc nous allons premières conclusions
le retour d'israël à sa terre
amputé je le rappelle des trois quarts
par les britanniques en 1923
est conforme à la fois aux différentes
décisions des organisations
internationales qui n'est d'ailleurs ne
peuvent pas revenir en arrière et
également au droit international dont
pour les choses soient très claires
l'occupation
par l'état d'israël de la judée samarie
est absolument juste et conforme et n'a
en fait évincer aucune et entités
étatiques préexistence pourquoi et bien
c'est bien simple toute la région que je
vous ai montré ici donc on appelle la
palestine une partie la palestine
historique n'a jamais été une entité
étatique
distante comme je l'expliqué tout à
l'heure pendant 400 ans depuis
1517 jusqu'à 1917 la palestine le pays
des juifs la terre sain la terre promise
faisait ans était en fait une province
poussiéreuse et éloignées et en
désolation totale de l'empiré ottoman de
nouveau sans vouloir faire une
explication trop importante et bien
tout le monde connaît mark twain tout le
monde connaît gustave flaubert coup tout
le monde connaît lamartine également des
récits de voyageurs et de géographes
depuis 2000 ans qui ont décrit la
désolation totale
du pays d'israël dont bien entendu la
judée samarie dont nous allons parler
maintenant d'un autre point
très rapidement également quelques
données donc je vous expliquer tout
alors revenons au petit pas en arrière
toute la superficie de l'état d'israël
est de 27 mille cinq cents kilomètres
carrés c'est à dire pour que vous avez
une bonne notion il s'agit en fait d'un
une superficie qui est deux fois la
normandie ou à peu près les deux tiers
de la suisse où la superficie de l'état
du new jersey aux états-unis c'est tout
petit ça représente d'ailleurs un
pourcentage infime
par exemple de deux des états unis ou
bien entendu la chine ou de la russie
encore plus c'est un tout petit pays à
l'intérieur donc de l'état d'israël vous
avez cette région
rapidement la galilée le golan la
galilée la plaine du ce du sharon est là
le negev le désert et là nous avons donc
la judée samarie que vous voyez ci un
petit peu plus clair voyez ici la mer
d'accord les villes de tel-aviv natanya
ashdod ashkelon etc et vous avez cet art
est montagneuse qui comme j'ai dit tout
à l'heure va de la vallée du jour de 10
elle d'accord jusqu'à donc beersheva
plus en commun que dans ce cas il faut
également savoir nous n'allons pas
rentrer aujourd'hui dans des
considérations
comment s'appelle stratégique que le ce
qu'on appelle la ligne verte qui n'a
jamais été une frontière c'était qui
délimite en fait voyez bien la judée
samarie qui était donc occupé
illégalement par la jordanie jusqu'à
1967 en fait fait que natanya est à 14
15 km pardon 15 km de cette fameuse
ligne verte qui est d'ailleurs une ligne
de cessez-le-feu donné que ici et il y
avait les pays arabes n'ont jamais voulu
reconnaître la moindre frontière avec
israël et jusqu'aujourd'hui les accords
de paix que la jordanie c'est et
l'egypte en fait on était le fait disons
de l'acceptation par ces pays arabes
n'ont pas de traité de paix à réel
jusqu'à présent mais davantage
d'ailleurs d'être de non belligérance
qu'est une différence puisque les choses
évoluent preuve pour l'instant mais nous
en traitons peut-être un peu plus tard
quoi qu'il en soit cette partie là donc
on appelle la judée samarie qui
va donc de là vers israël jusqu à
beersheva à une superficie de 5500
kilomètres carrés et comme je lé 17 une
arête montagneuse qui a environ une
moyenne de 600 à 800 mètres jusqu'à 1000
mais parce qu'en certains endroits est
alors en quoi c'est important cette
région est bien cet argent est très très
importante et le fait que beaucoup de
nations
ni au peuple juif et au peuple israélien
le droit à cette toute petite région
qui a été comme j'ai des douleurs
précédemment a été acquis de droit par
l'état d'israël puisque occupé
illégalement par notre pays qu'il n'y
avait pas le droit et bien en fait c'est
le pays où c'est la région pardon ou
80% des événements qui sont situés dans
le canard la bible
se trouve
et si vous rajoutez à cela vous rajoutez
la vallée de la vallée de gier elle est
le mont carmel vous rajoutez à cela
beersheva l'endroit où habitaient les
patriarches soient là vous apercevez que
90%
des événements qui sont rappelées cité
dans la bible se sont passées là bas
mais pas que cela lorsque les juifs ont
été exilés donc par les romains et bien
80% de la population juive habitait
également de cette région
c'est à dire en fait en d'autres termes
nous sommes revenus à la maison bien
entendu à cette époque là il y avait
également des juifs dans le sud est va
également ici mais n'oubliez pas qu'il y
avait des populations qui était un petit
post et donc les juifs s'étaient
concentrés ici et en quoi cette cette
région une importance particulière c'est
pas compliqué lorsque avram et c'est ce
qu'une fusion actuellement dans les
portions hebdomadaire que nous lisons la
torah et bien vient de abane ramdane et
bien en fait ils passent par sichem il
s'arrêtera à bethel il va aller
arriveront c'est à dire en fait lorsque
nous sommes en judée samarie
sans exagérer il n'y a pratiquement pas
un endroit
où il n'ya pas de réminiscences public
très forte à bt l'on vient d'en parler
pouvons également parlé de ofra ne
pouvons pas le déni remâche et cetera
lieu des batailles de david et jonathan
et cetera rêveront ou est très bonne où
est la le caveau des patriarches
sichem qui a été achetée donc pas par
par jacob donc là en fait c'est le coeur
biblique même du coeur d'israël et le
retour d'israël au coeur de sa terre
dérange apparemment pas mal de gens
toute histoire d'israël en particulier
autour d'israël est quelque chose qui à
la fois
rationnelle et illogique je vais
m'expliquer tout de suite il est évident
que dieu bénisse son peuple il est
évident également que le peuple juif a
fait ce qu'il fallait ne pas pis rennais
ont fait ce qu'il fallait mais dieu en
fait à permet les victoires du pubis
rays sur ses ennemis je voudrais
rappeler simplement
citation du talmud qui dit que la vérité
et le sceau de dieu étant donné que la
vérité est avec le peuple juif dans son
retour qui était annoncée donc comme je
le dis à 2800 en scoop exceptionnel donc
il est évident que s'il ya des
difficultés mais dieu bénisse son peuple
et
un petit peu aux dames bien entendu
d'une idéologie islamique qui ni au
peuple juif non seulement son existence
et qui tend il le dit de façon explicite
à l'éradication de l'état d'israël mais
les choses se passent pas tout à fait
comme je le voudrais et comme nous
l'avons tout à l'heure donc israël a
remporté genou répète également grâce à
dieu toutes les guerres attend en
parallèle israël est devenu un pays très
avancés
et
bien que
la plupart des musulmans des arabes
restent dans un chêne de position israël
pour des raisons idéologiques et entre
guillemets religieuses les choses se
passent assez bien pour istres est de
nouveau centre et d'entrain un
développement trop grand il est évident
que même les nations occidentales
qui par antisémitisme atavique essaye de
nuire à l'état d'israël commencent à
comprendre que la volonté clairement
manifesté clairement exprimées par les
pays arabes
jusqu'à présent
est semblable à l'idéologie guérir de
l'islam qui prêta en fait envahir
l'europe ou plus et man ray envahir
l'europe je vous rappellerai que l'islam
envahi
l'espagne en particulier et la france
jusque là poitiers une partie des pays
balkans et que jusqu'à présent
en fait tu considères l'espagne le sud
de la france et d'autres pays comme une
terre islamique ce qu'il ya en europe
dar es salaam sert l'espace de l'islam
les conséquences on les connaît
aujourd'hui
comment ça se passe en israël maintenant
alors de façon très intéressante les
arabes qui vivent en israël sont très
heureux pourquoi ils sont très heureux
parce que c'est le seul endroit au
moyen-orient où
les arabes vivent en démocratie tout
simplement deuxièmement le niveau
économique des arabes en israël est très
bon nous sommes dans un pays
d'économie libérale nous sommes dans un
pays de libertés de toutes les libertés
donc le monde arabe en israël vit très
bien donc il faut distinguer en fait
entre les arabes qui vivent en israël et
les arabes qui sont en dehors dit serait
dans les pays où en fait la propagande
antisémite
digne d'ailleurs souvent de l'époque
nazie est très vive mais les choses
changent peuple premièrement comme je le
disais précédemment les arabes en israël
sont très heureux c'est à dire que ils
ont la capacité
d'avoir accès à l'enseignement supérieur
ou services de santé d'israël et surtout
à quelque chose assez intéressant c'est
qu'il serait elle est un pays de pointe
dans énormément de domaines et là c'est
lié directement aux pays arabes
avoisinants qu'est ce qui se passe là
bas eh bien
ça prend du temps et à tel point que
l'arabie saoudite a lancé il ya environ
un mois ou deux un programme éducatif
pour essayer de corriger
l'antisémitisme atavique qu'il y en
arabie saoudite et pourquoi
et bien tout simplement pour différentes
raisons premièrement le monde arabe le
monde en particulier à bestiaux dit a
été entre guillemets lâché par les états
unis pour différentes raisons on va pas
rentrer dedans et aujourd'hui l'ennemi
commun
de l'arabie saoudite de l'egypte de la
jordanie et cetera c'est l'iran et ses
pires rap
par realpolitik comprennent très bien
que le seul partenaire sérieux
et de progrès dans la région et qui a un
avenir et qui a un avenir devant lui et
bien c'est israël si l'état n'y serait
pas seulement cela comme vous le savez
tous
il y a un besoin de moins en moins
important de pétrole
c'est à dire que nous acheminons le
monde entier vers en fait
à une suppression tv besoin de pétrole
en particulier dans le domaine
automobile mais ce n'est pas que le
moteur bi et des pays qu'on arabie
saoudite qui ont 85 % de leurs
ressources
basée sur le pétrole sont repassés en
pétrole et qui n'ont aucune aucune
économie
productive structure et s'aperçoivent
que les juifs revenu en israël depuis
100 ans de façon massive et bien on crée
dans quelque chose qui était un désert
complet en désolation complète on crée
un pays dans lequel poussent
pratiquement tous les fruits du monde et
tous les légumes du monde et a bâti une
industrie en pointe
israël sano sujet également abordé est
en fait un pays qui par tête d'habitant
a le plus de start up dans le monde une
économie une agriculture très développé
et surtout surtout surtout israël de par
les contraintes régional à développer
des technologies dans le domaine de
l'eau qui sont très importantes est
vital aujourd'hui pour beaucoup de pays
en particulier la chine l'inde l'afrique
les pays arabes et donc nos voisins donc
de plus en plus part comme je le disais
à l'instant par realpolitik les pays
arabes s'aperçoivent que en fin de
compte ils n'ont pas de choix
ils vont devoir c'est un processus qui a
commencé ça va prendre 10 ans 20 ans
mais s'est déjà engagé et c'est
irréversible pour des contraintes tout
simplement économiques et économiques et
sécuritaires donc passe aujourd'hui
c'est payé rapaces aujourd'hui des
accords
de totalement que totalement a découvert
avec israël dans les domaines à la fois
sécuritaire on n'a pas un instant la
menace de l'islam et surtout dans le
domaine économique pourquoi parce que
des pays qui ont bâti une économie
uniquement sur l'exploitation d'un
pétrole dont on n'a plus besoin vont
être nécessairement
nécessairement être
confronté un problème qui ne peuvent pas
résoudre tout seul n'oubliez pas
également que les états unis ne sont
plus intéressés par les pays arabes
puisque il ya plus aucun et connaît tous
un terreau économies je vous rappellerai
d'ailleurs il me semble que ça réveille
au général de gaulle qu en politique il
n'ya pas de sentiments inhale des
intérêts donc aujourd'hui en volte face
l'intérêt des pays arabes en particulier
de l'egypte et d'être partenaire avec
israël à la fois dans les domaines de
construction d'une infrastructure
d'économie productive et également dans
le domaine sécuritaire
on posait la question de l'unesco
écoutez si
j'ai entendu cet après midi la
déclaration du député claude claude
goasguen à l'assemblée nationale et je
vous invite à la regarder sur youtube
c'est très facile à trouver
l'unesco est censé être l'organisme
organisation enfin l'organisme des états
unis des nations unies qui s'occupe de
choses culturelles
alors il ya plusieurs points d'abord
cette décision entre guillemets de
l'unesco est stupide pour plusieurs
raisons la très court mais pour
commençons par le début il faut savoir
que jérusalem
n'est pas une ville sainte pour l'islam
jérusalem est une ville sainte avant
tout pour le peuple juif et pour la
chrétienneté et je mexplique jérusalem
est mentionné 669 fois dans le canard
dans la bible
et n'est pas mentionné une seule fois
dans le coran mieux que ça cette fameuse
polémique sur le mur aussi intimidant
talent en fait c'est l'enceinte
construit par hérode de l'esplanade du
temple au premier temple de salomon du
roi salomon et deuxième temple et il ya
même un comment s'appelle un guide qui a
été rédigée en
1924 ou 25 par le wac qui était donc le
40 entre guillemets des lieux saints
musulmans qui décrit et je peux vous
donner très facilement la différence qui
dit simplement qu'il n'ait fait aucun
doute ou plus exactement il est hors de
discussion que l'espérer à dutemple sur
laquelle et hume et sont baptisés de
mosquées et en fait l'esplanade là où
était bâti le temple de salomon et puis
ensuite le second temps donc cette
décision de l'eau de l'unesco est une
décision politique qui est en fait
comment s'appelle
guidés par les pays arabes en
particulier
perdre pays ennemis à israël c'est une
décision totalement stupide qui n'a
aucune signification et qui en fait
croyant menace état d'israël en fait est
une attaque directe dirigée contre la
chrétienneté puisqu'il est évident que
de nier le lien juifs
entre le peuple juif et jérusalem est en
particulier l'endroit des spa nahd du
temple ça veut dire également de façon
très curieuse nier en fait toute
l'histoire de la chrétienneté c'est à
dire
la venue et la présence de jésus christ
à jérusalem dans le temple donc il est
évident quelque chose de curieux en fait
c'est une des manifestations par une
partie de l'occident d'une soumission à
l'islam c'est un sujet immense beaucoup
entre est aujourd'hui nous en parlons
pas maintenant